vous étiez très favorisée par mail à
vous étiez vraiment son chouchou
à ce qu'il paraît angela mah révélé
qu'au début m6 ne voulait pas de moi en
plus alors celle acquise il aurait même
c'est devenu la papesse de la télé
réalité après la produit d'une
interpellation et c est l avec
évidemment la première aventure avec
nous elle était en charge
ldd des candidats c'était votre nounou
en fait à we say say on lui doit enfin
moi c'est l'une des bonnes fées où tu
mon berceau incontestablement même et
angela c'est vraiment peur et s'est
vraiment battu pour moi et démystifie
c'est un personnage tard le batofar
si les pâtes dans le loft savoie l'autre
question pour voter ah mince alors
séville quel garçon du loft et ton style
saison non mais c'est vrai je fais vous
savez d'art cgt on s'arrête de joie là
ça fait deux fois qui dit il était très
beau jour de romarin c'est toujours un
un maillage se trouvait à l'époque cc
nouvellement h c'était le prince
charmant jean-edouard effet cette
couleur douches de la piscine est
différente et sylvie c'est vrai que je
sais pas s'il y avait eu d'été pour
communiquer sur la sexualité des uns et
les autres on l'a fait dans la saison 2
puisqu'on a eu droit un coming out avec
avec thomas mais mais mais vous vous
avez clairement affiché quelque chose ou
pas du tout vous en avez pas parlé puis
moi même j'étais je ne savais pas
vraiment où j'étais non plus donc
d'accord non non et puis surtout j'en
avais pas parlé à mon père n'avait pas
parlé à ma mère
donc même s'ils se sont doutés qui m'ont
tendu des perches j'ai jamais saisi la
perche parce que voilà et puis l'époque
n'était pas celle d'aujourd'hui l'époque
c'était quand même différent à l'époque
il fallait avoir le cran de le dire
assez c'est vrai c'est que moi même ne
brille et à l'apd est aussi servi à ça
au début parce que j'ai eu après le loft
une multitude de l'être mais beaucoup de
lettres me disant merci grâce à toi j'ai
découvert que mes parents et aimait bien
les gays
c'est plus facile de le dire mais j'ai
même essayé de l'être
on peut le dire les missions mine de
rien elle a fait avancer dans la
mentalité de beaucoup de gens essaient
lapointe fois que les parents et les
grands parents voyaient vivre un leurs
enfants mais c'est la conduire ça mais
c'est la vérité quand même merci
beaucoup de témoignages de plusieurs
aujourd'hui 1